Based on the question I want to answer.
At this point the next task
that would make sense for
me to do is to split
the data into two groups.
Data for students who eventually
pass the first project and for
students who don't.
But I have all this data about students'
engagement in the first week, and
I'm getting curious.
I want to take a look at it.
My rule of thumb is when I'm curious
about my data, I investigate.
Getting a better sense of your
data is almost always useful.
In this case,
I'll probably be able to reuse some
of the code I'm writing later.
But even if that weren't true, exploring
your data is never a waste of time for
a data analyst.